es gibt eine neue wendung im fall der
verborgenen cummard der cheops-pyramide
die im letzten jahr entdeckt wurde ein
italienischer astrophysiker und archäo
astronomie jetzt eine wirklich spannende
erklärung entwickelt was sich in der
kammer verdrückten das scheint mehr als
pure luft zu sein
es wäre ein wirklich unglaublicher
schatz was es ist und warum es sich dort
verbergen soll jetzt sind klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen ja
ich habe mich noch mal mit der
aussprache von jobs ein bisschen
beschäftigt tatsächlich in
süddeutschland und österreich wird krebs
gesagt deswegen sage ich in diesem video
mal wieder shops und vielleicht
demnächst mal wieder anders
anfang november 2017 haben wir darüber
berichtet in der jobs pyramide wurde ein
riesiger hohlraum entdeckt über den
inhalt beziehungsweise dem zweck
schießen die spekulationen jetzt ins
kraut ob und es gibt eine erste
forschungsarbeit das von einem
renommierten astrophysiker und archäo
astronomie juli ist professor an der
polytec nico in mailand und dort
direktor der mathematischen fakultät
astronomie ist ein spezialgebiet der
archäologie und beschäftigt sich mit der
astronomischen bedeutung von relikten
und bauten aus der vergangenheit und da
ist ägypten natürlich eine wahre
schatztruhe und vielleicht in diesem
fall sogar im wahrsten sinne des wortes
juli hat sich jetzt mit dem hohlraum
beschäftigt und ist zu sehr
interessanten schlüssen gekommen aber
erst noch mal zum hohlraum und wir
entdeckt wurde
denn auch das ist schon eine absolute
sensation er wurde nämlich mit
teilchenphysik entdeckt er wird schon
als die entdeckung des jahrhunderts
bezeichnet die kammer ist wirklich
riesig 30 meter lange acht meter hoch
und breit oberhalb der galerie also das
kann es der zur königs kammer führt und
die entdeckung mit teilchenphysik
funktionierte so millionen haben die
kammern nachgewiesen sie entstehen wenn
protonen aus dem weltall auf unserer
atmosphäre treffen dabei zerfallen
atomkerne und es entstehen diese million
sie sind wie elektronen negativ geladen
zerfallen aber bereits nach 22
millisekunden von außen betrachtet
existieren sie aber viel länger die
relativitätstheorie macht es möglich
bewegen sie sich fast mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit fort deshalb wirkt
die zeit delegation auf sie und sie
haben für uns rund zehn mal mehr zeit
bis sie zerfallen in dieser zeit können
sie die erdoberfläche erreichen auf dem
weg durch materie werden sie dann
abgelenkt fliegen sie nicht durch
materie werden sie eben nicht april
erstellt man in einer pyramide also
unterhalb eines hohlraums detektoren auf
treffen dort mehr millionen auf als
unter einer dicken stein schicht wie mit
einem so konstruierten heutigen gerät
können jetzt hohlräume entdeckt werden
und genau das ist jetzt passiert
oberhalb der galerie muss es nach den
messungen der teilchenphysiker zu
sicheren einen hohlraum geben 30 meter
lang und acht meter hoch und breit aber
was verbirgt sich in dieser kammer hat
sich erstmal mit der literatur
beschäftigt und ist auf interessantes
gestoßen
seine quelle sind die pyramiden texte
das sind texte die sich an den
innenwänden der pyramiden und an den
innenseiten der serie finden dort ist
ein eiserner thron erwähnt auf dem zitat
aus der forschungsarbeit der verstorbene
pharao bevor er die nördlichen sterne
erreicht die tore zum himmel passiert ja
platz nehmen muss nun gibt es genau
solche tore zum himmel der pyramide das
jedenfalls vermutet man dass sie genau
diese tore sein können sie sind am ende
zweier schächte im süden und im norden
das tor am ende des südlichen schachtes
wurde schon genauer untersucht beim
nördlichen schacht ist das aber noch
nicht geschehen und er endet genau da wo
der verborgene hohlraum vermutet wird
also wo er so ungefähr sein können die
genaue lage konnte nämlich bisher noch
nicht ermittelt werden ja wenn es so
wäre dann könnte sich hinter diesem
nördlichen himmels tor zum einen dieser
hohlraum befinden und zum anderen ein
wirklich unglaublicher schatz ein
eiserner thron wäre so ziemlich der
unglaublichste und wertvollste schatz
der vorzeit denn und das ist wirklich
absolut faszinierend damals konnte noch
gar kein eisen aus eisenerz gewonnen
werden die technik war einfach noch
nicht entwickelt trotzdem gab es schon
relikte und gibt es auch heute noch aus
eisen und sie waren damals
wahrscheinlich das wertvollste was man
besitzen konnte das eis
damals nannte sich himmels eisen und
dafür gibt es einen faszinierenden und
einfachen grund das eisen kam aus dem
alle bot ja es stand von eisen methoden
dieses eisen konnte nämlich schon
relativ einfach bearbeitet werden war
aber natürlich extrem selten mangels
vermutung in der kammer befindet sich
ein ton aus solchen reisen gebaut wie
zum beispiel der thron von joops mutter
hätte faires das heißt dass die
konstruktion aus holz ist er aber mit
eisen verkleidet werden während andere
forschungsteams vorschlagen irgendwie
mit endoskopen durch das gestein in den
neuen hohlraum zu gelangen hat magie
jetzt einen ganz konkreten plan die
himmels tore also himmelstor man weiß es
ja nicht ob sie sehen wir sind am ende
des nördlichen ganz sollen genauer
untersucht werden er kann sich
vorstellen dass man so zur geheimen
kammern gelangt und dann diesen
unglaublichen schatz entdecken wird das
ist ja mal eine konkrete idee und
vielleicht wird dann schon bald weiter
geforscht wenn es neuester so gibt dann
erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier wenn er
kein video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird
mir hier kein abo aufsaugen vergessen
ich denen genau auf die glocke nur dann
verpasst er kein video hier geht es
weiter also hier dafür draufklicken
mysteriöses rätsel um nasca linien
endlich gelüftet ja und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran